bella tutti ragazzi e per il suo video
sono qua dj e dal menu che state vedendo
potrete sicuramente notare che questo
gioco intelligente bene nel caso non ve
ne foste accorti e un gioco simile ma
molto simile ago simulator l'unica roba
che cambia e che non sei una capra
massei perdonami se questa persona che
va a tirare calci alla gente ma devo
andare assolutamente a buttare giustizia
ovunque finisca tiro di roba la faccia
una banana è la madonna era una parola
non un missile sono un killer ma gas ha
detto pippo guarda che brutta cosa sto
vedendo
[Musica]
sono cagato addosso solo una palla zio
calmati con quale fisica una palla può
farmi questo spiega mi che problemi hai
al cervello ma posso uscire e fare le
cose io esco la tua ma volendo posso
guidare le cose tipo sarebbe stato figo
frate devi controllarti però cosa sto
vedendo passa ci passa c ok ragazzi
gioco io vi giuro simulator in confronto
è e assassin's creed è confrontata roba
ma cos'è gianfrate sei ubriaco ci
ubriachiamo insieme cos'è sta roba
in realtà ragazzi io sto facendo tutto
il rag doll perché non lo so però va
bene fatti i corrieri che il pacco di
amazon non è questo mio pacco di anno
con sei perché il suo turno corriere non
è neanche quando arriva il corriere e
sei felice banchiere
hai un outfit che dolce gabbana
spostatevi ciardi ha così io rimorchio
le donne c'è una festa che cosa cazzo
state facendo ma è il vostro problema
parquet va non ci si picchia davanti a
me smettila di ballare mi dà fastidio
non si caga con la tavolozza chiusa la
tavolozza del cesso prix per gli artisti
ci fa il quadro nel cesso a tu vendi
haters può allora quando io ero in
giappone avevi successo che gli sparava
l'acqua nel culo era bellissimo me lo
fai vedere io ho scassato il computer ma
se volete lo riguarda se vuoi ciao
basta prendere a pugni il terreno basta
che palle smettila di dimenarsi se non
ti sta toccando nessuno tranne io
proprio un dettaglio
veramente non ci voglio credere che
comandi incredibile no no no ho
sbagliato tasto lo smalto da accordano e
ti prego e vabbè mi sembra che mickey è
scatenata lega scatenata dai fermati per
fermare guido io perché utilizzare una
moto quando è il tappeto di aladino
paghi e rifatte capire come faccio a
guidare
io vorrei posso salire su una moto
maledetto
io sono entrato nel parabrezza così ma
vi rendete conto del bureau ti fai
guidare per cortesia e fantastico il
fatto che tu riesca a curvare senza
utilizzare le braccia posso anche fare
il front fit ma che storia è che è
frontflip aggiungerei applaude che c'è
una morte
per terra l'audi la musica di sto già
bella ma vabbè ok va bene
best fisica e berlina videogame
porca [ __ ] lancia scivola un po troppo
mi sa che c'è una macchina grazie a dio
meno male che c'è una macchina perché se
non sapevo come di alzarmi in piedi bebè
perché c'è una mucca non lo voglio
sapere
andiamo sicuramente a testare se le
rampe funzionano quindi proviamo ci fai
con me sì non ho dubbi infatti funziona
davvero non ci avrei mai sperato in
realtà permesso salve vorrei
questo è un ottimo modo di fare le
flessioni e gli addominali in un momento
in dubbio ma quello e benji di benji e
fede non voglio sapere perché quando si
stava limone salve via di qua via di qua
bella raga 130 markin garics animals si
vola simon successo sono passato vicino
al demonio per un attimo cos'era
consigliate perché se mi avvicino 4
celle si annerisce tutto cos'è è una
setta satanica cos'è
[Musica]
ma che cazzo ballando thriller ma come
thriller di michael jackson
va bene che sei megan a zia per un po di
contegno maghetto ma cosa è esattamente
così che si va offrirò allergia o hai
capito tutto
vai frate per vedere chi sei ma sono dei
roller magnetici mi sono attaccato al
portone cosa
ciao zio allora ragazzi deciso di fare
una scampagnata del deserto perché tutto
questo mi mia città
no grazie berta lo sapevo che sia la
macchina può andare sull'acqua wat quota
fa non mi lasciare zia nomi lasciare non
mi lasciare nomi lasciare non mi lasciai
riservi grazie a dio ti si è schiantata
ferma mobile queste come la macchina di
harry potter se ne vado nell'amichevole
siamo arrivati in piscina non chiedetemi
come vorremmo stendermi io però mi sa
che ok perfetto adesso c'è posto per me
che bella la vita da piscina rilassante
vuoi dirmi che cosa minchia stai facendo
vuoi dirmi perché se i straiato così sei
a tuo agio sul trampolino zio
sicuramente ti ho dato una mano per non
è non è incentrata non hai centrato la
piscina frate e ce ne voleva né
esattamente gang amstein terrà presso lo
stile di geri fabi console
ragazzi questo super pezzo che vi metto
martin harris o quanto amo il mio lavoro
guardalinee
ecco la song a dati dai sono incastrato
col piede nel marciapiede non avevo
dubbi
sapete che cosa devo fare ragazzi sì sì
sì sì sì non ci credo che culo
no ma no non ci voglio credere perché ho
schiacciato il tasto sbagliato perfetto
perfetto perfetto termina mai zio porca
vacca c'ero non posso guidare dai fronte
che palle non la posso guidare sarebbe
stato fighissimo mi accontento va bene
anche così ragazzi l'obiettivo è
raggiunto
va bene così non importa questo la mia
obiettivo per oggi pensate che traguardi
incredibili che ho nella vita io quindi
regazzoni e dire che con questo
bellissimo posso grazie direi che con
questo bellissimo carrello a razzo a
propulsione io posso concludere qui il
video di oggi spero più video vi sia
piaciuto spero che giocare a un qualcosa
di intelligente del solito sia
apprezzabile per voi
quindi ragazzi cosa induce il connettore
vi piace anche ai social come ne yo
stata ness cristiane se siete lì
ma dove cazzo è finito sociali siete ci
vediamo il prossimo video dai ragazzi
[Musica]